hi there today we'll look at transgan
two transformers can make one strong gan
by yifan chiang shi chang and
chang yang wang so in this paper
the authors attempt to make a generative
adversarial network
again out of only transformers
so far attention or transformer like
things
have been used in gans but they've
always had some component of
convolutions in there this paper
attempts to do
generator and discriminator just
using transformers they discuss
what is needed to do that how they built
the architecture
and there are a couple of training
tricks that
make this work and actually make this
competitive
to current state-of-the-art
architectures so
the biggest data set they tackle is
celeb a which is
64 by 64 pixels but you know due to
their numbers suggest you can scale this
much larger
the model is called transgan
i i don't know if this is a bit of an
unfortunate
uh naming i guess the question is which
bathroom do
the trans gang go to uh i don't know
in any case let's dive into the paper
let's check it out
if you like content like this share it
out leave a like
and tell me what you think in the
comments so the paper
is fairly straightforward actually
there is code available so definitely
check that out i'll link that of course
in the description the paper is fairly
straightforward
and answers one question can we build
a strong gan completely free of
convolutions
so usually in gans you have convolutions
both in the generator and the
discriminator
and their goal is to just replace
that using transformers as we say
they're contributions there are three
the model architecture so the
discriminator as we're going to see
is a vision transformer like we saw
before the generator is also a
transformer
that is interlaced with up sampling
then training technique they do discuss
that you do
need three things specifically
so you do need data augmentation you
need multi-task
code training for the generator and you
need a
localized initialization for the
self-attention
in order to make this work
and then they reach a gan so their model
their biggest model transcan
xl reaches very competitive fid scores
and also very competitive inception
scores
wait this is f ah here here is the
inception score
um the i s score is a bit of a misnomer
too i mean the s
is already score but you know who
it's it's okay um yeah
so first architecture the architecture
is
fairly straightforward so for again you
need a discriminator
and a generator now the discriminator
as i already said here that is the exact
model from v i t and i've done video
about it the paper is called
a picture is worth 16 by 16
pixels or something like this well i
don't exactly remember
but um you can you can check you can
definitely find that
it is a transformer based image
classifier
so what you do with an image so here you
see an example image this image of the
dog
what you would see if you were to feed
this into the discriminator of course
the discriminator gets
the output from the generator but also
the real data
you would you would unroll that picture
into
these kind of sub pixels as you can see
right here uh but not into full pixels
but into kind of these super pixels
so every one of those super pixels will
then be
unrolled this is this flattening
operation right here
into a single vector and that then
is like a word in a sentence okay so
this picture here just becomes a
series of vectors and then you can
simply apply
your regular transformer architecture
so every patch becomes a vector like a
word embedding
and then you just go ahead and you put a
transformer encoder so this is very much
like bert for example
it is a similar architecture as you say
you can go look at this paper
and at the end you simply classify
whether it's real or
fake you do have to add position
encodings because
you know lacking the convolutions the
transformer
has no idea where in the picture
a given uh given thing appears
because it is not a sequential
architecture it's actually a set
transformation
architecture so you do need to add
positional encodings
but in general this has been shown to
work quite well in things like imagenet
classification
on the generator side it is very similar
but you know a little bit different so
here what you need to achieve
are of course um
are these 32 by 32 by 3
pixel image right that's at the end
you need to achieve that now you can't
just go the reverse from over here and
somehow try to
uh predict these patches because
that i guess that is just too
you know if you predict these patches as
such like independent patches from each
other
the borders would never match up in a
discriminator this is not
does not matter because you don't need
to construct the image you
simply need to classify it but if you
need to generate images
it's you know it doesn't look good if
you have these borders here where things
don't match up so you will actually need
to produce
an image that is in the size that you
require so in this case
yeah 32 by 32 and of course three
color channels so the way they achieve
it
is by this upsampling architecture the
problem
with transformers of course is they do
require
quite a bit of memory and and also
compute
because the attention mechanism
basically connects
every single token with every single
other token in each transformation
in this case they connect every pixel to
every other pixel
now if you were to do this for many many
layers
that is going to be you know 32 squared
in this case
memory requirements pretty quickly you
will
run into problems so what they do is
they have
intrinsic upscaling of their dimensions
what does that mean so at the beginning
you have like some
some noise input and you have a little
mlp generating the initial sequence now
the initial sequence is going to be
eight by eight by number of channels you
can see there are also position
encodings right here
so your noise generator essentially
creates
an eight by eight grid okay
um let's say for the sake of argument we
create a two by two grid instead of an
eight by eight
with a number of channels so here is the
number of channels
to the back you wanna unroll those
into four vectors of the these channels
one two three four you get the idea
and then that you feed into the
transformer so now you have
four tokens or here uh 64 tokens in that
case but
in our case four tokens that you feed to
the transformer so right now
at this stage this is like a sentence
with four different words
so you run that through m layers of the
transformer
and then at some point you decide okay
now it's time to do
upscaling and the upscaling
in the upscaling you take
those four words so you take that two by
two
image that you have right here with the
c channels
and you generate somehow from it and
we're going to look at i'm going to draw
this over here
so you generate somehow
an image that is double the
density in pixels
so this is now a 4x4 image but
it has less channels so the way they
save memory
is that they start out with many
channels but
very very coarse resolution and
progressively as they go
up the layers they up sample
so that they have more resolution but
less
channels okay and the exact so this is
this is very much like um like the
convolutional
gans do so like they they would start
out with a very
coarse image grid and then they do some
kind of up sampling some kind of strided
pooling
and so on in order to reach higher
um higher pixel densities and with the
higher pixel densities they often
decrease the number of channels
so you get a trade-off between the
density and the
kind of depth of information at the end
they end up with their target resolution
and a number of channels and then they
feed that
through a small they feed each
individually
through a small um linear projection
in order to project that to the three
channels
so that's how they end up with three
channels so how exactly does this
up sampling work so by the way i hope
you can you can see the
the whole pipeline now right you start
out by this is this is sort of a noise
generated
this is what is derived from the noise
and then the input is just
transformed transformed transformed up
sampled
transformed some more upsampled
transformed some more
until it is at the target resolution
thereby
in the lower layers you have lots of
information depth
not much resolution in the higher layer
you have lots of resolution
but not that much information depth
anymore so
the computations higher up might be more
localized they might be more to do
with the exact kind of um
the exact details of that particular
patch in the image right all of these
things are representative of patches
especially in the down
scaled like this pixel right here is
representative
of all the pixels that are going to be
generated out of it
so of this one one layer higher and of
course
one even one layer higher it's going to
be of
its own four by four pixel grid so the
computation you do down here on this
pixel
will affect all of these pixels later
the way they do the up sampling is by
this pixel shuffle algorithm
that they have from this paper right
here
and i'll link to that of course as well
so this is a paper that was
as i understand it originally derived
for convolutions and it asked how can we
do
sort of convolutional operation um
on high resolution images without having
to
do the compute for high resolution
images and they figured out
that if they had if they had
a high resolution image they can sort of
represent they can
rearrange a high resolution image into a
smaller
resolution image with more channels so
here
you see you have they they call this r
squared number of channels
so this number here is r squared
and they can sort of unroll this image
into this one
and they do that by treating
these things here maybe you can see this
is a repeating pattern
as sort of super pixels and see that
so one of these super pixels is going to
be one
column here
all right so
this this way so you you're gonna
upsample
by having lots of channels here doing
the computation on
as if they were lots of channel in a low
resolution image
and then you up sample by just unrolling
the channels
locally so by treating each of these
things
as just you know one super pixel with
the
elements of the channels being the you
know kind of the different pixels in the
neighborhood
so you want to unroll that and then
after that you
continue um with your processing with
putting this
through the next layers until you up
sample it again by unrolling some more
channels
i hope that's clear so you're going to
start out with a lot of channels
because each time you unroll you're
going to lose some of them you're going
to trade off some of the channels
channel depth for more resolution
all right so here you can see every time
they up sample their resolution by two
they need to divide the channels by four
because you need to up sample by two in
the width
and in the height direction actually
it's not even
necessary you can totally you can
totally choose this because
in the attention block as you can see
here sorry in the transformer block
you have this part which is the
attention mechanism
and then you also have this part right
here especially this
mlp here it takes in each token of these
it takes that after it you know it goes
through the attention after the whole
thing goes through the attention
each of the tokens is fed separately
through the mlp so the mlp there is
it's actually not necessary that the
output dimension of the mlp
is the same as the input dimension
except for
this skip connection right here now if
this skip connection
like in resnet had some sort of a linear
projection as well
then you could totally think of
think of changing the dimensions here
but i'm not even
i'm not even sure if you do the
projection isn't this just the same as
the mlp
with if you feed each individually
maybe maybe there's no point in having
the skip connection at all
in any case um you could probably get
around that
you know that requirement to have this
exact number of channels nevertheless
that's what they do uh so
the generator is actually manageable
memory wise
because it does this this trade-off as
it progresses up
it generates an actual grid in the
resolution
of the image in with the required
channels
being a projection of the final channels
here out of the transformer
then it's fed into the discriminator the
discriminator uh
immediately divides the image into
patches interprets each
as sort of a token embedding and then
simply
it adds positional encodings and then
simply uses a transformer
like like bert and at the end you have
this cls token like you have invert
and that classifies real or fake you can
backprop through the whole architecture
and that's again
for you so that was the architecture
part
and now so they do they do initial they
do a lot of
good ablations where they say okay what
if we
what if so we have a generator and the
discriminator what if we have
kind of this autogan is what they is one
of the things they compare with
so what if we do that and then what if
we just replace
the generator with the transformer what
if we just replace the discriminator
so they find out that they can they can
replace the generator just fine
and that even gives you know gives
competitive performance
as soon as they you know transfer the
discriminator to
a transformer that drops in performance
so in order to really make this work
they need some more tricks
they have three tricks the first trick
is data augmentation
they say data augmentation is crucial
for transgen
and the type of data augmentation they
do is also from a
paper for data augmentation for gans
it's this right here
differentiable augmentation for data
efficient training so the whole point is
that your data augmentation so the
augmentation
t right here is a differentiable
function so data augmentation is things
like
cropping or changing the brightness
color jitter
rotating and so on so as long as that's
a
differentiable operation you can use
this technique right here
where you back prop through the
augmentation
you can see right here in the generator
update you actually
back prop so the back propagation
happens through the
t function and therefore you get
a much better signal plus you get all
the benefits of data augmentation
and the point they make in the transgand
paper here is that
given that transformers don't have this
convolution they don't have this
locality bias built into their
architecture
they need a lot more data and we know
that transformers they work well
if you have an abundant amount of data
and you can
sort of get around having lots of data a
little bit
by using data augmentation so they argue
that data augmentation
it works for all gans but it helps a lot
more
in these transformer based scans because
the transformers
benefit better from having lots of data
again the story about transformers is
pretty
clear i think if you have lots of data
they tend to work well because they're
just a more general
architecture so here you can see in the
different
gans you can see that the the
augmentation which is when the check
mark here is
it helps sometimes you can see not
always sometimes here it does
fairly well but here in the turn in the
trans scan
you can see that adding data
augmentation drastically improves the
results
and already gets these gans into the
ballpark
of um the state of the art not yet there
there's still a big difference but it
gets it you know gets them
gets them in in like target distance
so the second trick they have is this
code training with the self-supervised
auxiliary task and specifically
they do super resolution so
so we're going to write this so this
here this it's a super resolution task
right
super resolution
and what they mean by this is simply
they in in addition to the whole
gan training right so here you
have the data set data set i know
beautiful
so the discriminator over here the d it
gets
images from the gan as you can see right
here and it also gets images
from the data set right and that's your
main gan loss so here you have the
discriminator loss you back propagate
that
through the gan you update all the
parameters what you also do
is you take data set images you put them
here
as a target so this is the target
for the gan so the gan needs to output
something and what does it get as an
input it gets
this thing but scaled down so
i'm gonna say this big picture goes to
small picture
okay so you take pictures from your data
set and you
deliberately down sample them you
deliberately
you might even add some noise or
something but i guess they simply do
lower resolution so lr means low
resolution
and then the task of the gan
is from the low resolution input predict
like it needs to predict
the high resolution image this is a this
it's completely different pipeline than
usually
because it actually gets the small thing
the small real image
as an input the gan usually never the
generator usually never sees real data
right now it gets it gets a small
resolution this is not the same image
that goes to the discriminator
uh by the way i think at least
this is just a different thing you can
also do you mix
into your batches of you know noise
gan samples with this loss you simply
also mix
things you mix this loss right here the
super resolution loss so you have this
loss
and then you have the loss from the
super resolution
and you simply add them with a parameter
to you know trade off one or the other
and this helps the generator
to so given a low resolution image
these stages here will have to learn to
sort of
upsample realistic looking images from
lower resolution images
and that's what you sort of expect this
gown to do
so it makes sense that uh this is a good
auxiliary task
and this turns out to help quite a bit
so as you can see right here here they
have it
with data augmentation and
if you add this task here it you know
the scores improve
again by a bit and then
the last trick they have is to also do
this
locality aware initialization for
self-attention
and you can see that again pushes the
scores
so what is this last trick in this last
trick they say
look the the convolution it seems to be
a pretty good prior for images
after all right that's why i mean that's
why cnns are so
effective it seems to be a good prior to
look locally
like to have local features but
of course the transformers they are more
powerful
and eventually they want to look at the
whole picture
but maybe it makes sense to first teach
them that
local things matter and once they're at
a certain quality level
we can kind of let them look at other
pixels in the image so what they do is
they hand craft a schedule and
so over the course of training they have
this gradually increasing receptive
field
so in early training they simply say
you're only allowed
to look at your immediate neighborhood
so each super pixel right here remember
this is in a downscaled world
sometimes during in the generator
you're only you're only
allowed to look at this at the immediate
neighbors so we introduce a mask
that says it here by which each query is
only allowed to interact with its local
neighbors that are not
masked okay and then say different from
previous methods during training we
gradually reduce the mask
until diminishing it eventually
self-attention is fully
global okay so
at first they say you know in the in the
transformer layer
you have you have the you have the keys
down here they have a series of keys and
you have a series
of queries from the individual tokens
and they say for a particular token
you're only allowed to look
at your immediate neighbors
as if you aggregate information and then
later they say okay now training so
this only look at this and you can only
look at
your immediate neighbors and so on and
later in training
they say okay now you've sort of learned
well you're now allowed
to also gather information from kind of
further out
until at the end of training the all the
queries are allowed to
look at all the keys i'm sure that if
you
engineer this smartly this is local
attention right this is known as local
attention
um and you can also make a bunch of
you know speed ups probably in early
training here you can see right here in
early stage only immediate neighbors
in middle stage they sort of widen the
circle of where you're allowed to look
and in the final stage each query is
actually allowed to do the full
attention so you know when i saw this i
was like
okay here i'm told we're gonna build
a gan absolutely without convolutions
all we're going to replace with is kind
of
an a linear operation that
is applied over the whole image
in a fashion that it only gets to look
at its neighbors
right it's totally not a convolution
it's just a linear operation that is
applied equally across the image
while only looking at your immediate
neighbors i'm so glad we're building
gans
without convolutions convolutions are
for losers
we're all for locally applied linear
transformations over the whole image
that
only can look at their immediate
neighbors
so yeah no i mean you get the point this
is
this is essentially a an attentionist
version of a convolution but within
with training as training progresses
they do release that constraint
this is simply to help the gandu
training
though i am fairly convinced what you
you wouldn't maybe have to do this as a
fixed schedule right this is like a
fixed schedule i say okay
you know at you you're allowed to look
at this many neighbors and then after
this many steps this
this and so on i'm fairly convinced you
could somehow formulate this maybe as a
two-player game
right but like like another gan thing or
maybe
yeah maybe another gan thing or sort of
an
uh self-play thing where
the one player tries to sort of
get the most information out of the
neighborhood
and the other player tries to sort of
constrain that player
and but it only has a certain amount of
budget and so on i'm not sure
i mean i but you could probably do
something smarter
uh than simply a fixed schedule that is
adaptive to the difficulty of the task
and you would also in turn lose a
bunch of hyper parameters that you need
to build this
this schedule over here
all right the last thing they do after
all the tricks
is of course what everyone does best
with transformers and that's just
scaling that thing up too
many layers many dimensionalities
and i don't know if they do a lot more
data probably not in this case but if
you had more data would also work better
and thereby they do reach you know
scores that are
state of the art or at least very
competitive with
state of the art so their transcan xl
model
as you can see here for example on c410
they do reach very competitive scores
beaten only by
stalgan v2 they also reach very good
or state of the art scores on other data
sets here on
stl10 they are the best
uh yeah so there is a it's
cool um by the way this it's it's nice
to see papers going back to kind of the
64 by 64 images because
uh we're so used to these super duper
high resolution gans now
this reminds me of old times uh yeah
so the the paper as as a whole is pretty
cool
um it's actually pretty straightforward
as i said
they develop an architecture that works
that is actually computable with this
kind of upsampling and the
pixel shuffle channel reduction
as they go along the vit discriminator
then they present three tricks to make
that work
it's data augmentation it's super
resolution
task as a code training task and
it's this localized attend local
locality aware initialization for the
attention
with the decreasing with the schedule
over training
and finally they scale that model up and
that
gives them pretty pretty well performing
again and it's only made
of so it has no convolutions their goal
isn't to use only transformers the goal
is actually to use no convolutions
yeah that was it for me tell me what you
think in the comments
and i invite you to check out the paper
and the code bye-bye